bobby has um
has a gift for all of us for chinese new
year oh
oh my god oh wow
thank you that's some durian fruit what
yeah
oh fancy durian food has it ever been
living it looks like it was something
that was alive ones
yeah it was living i'll get killed i cut
myself right here including it
come here babe come to me come to me and
um have you had durian
no come on to mike come on tonight
between
here let me hold this uh-huh tell us
what you have today
well this right here is
this right here is durian fruit and um
yeah yeah yeah let's just assume a mango
was in vegas
right he had no money and he prostituted
himself to get a
ticket back home i feel like a mango is
a girl bobby obviously
right and um it's basically if
you know a mango um could take a [ __ ]
that's what it is do you like it no i
[ __ ] hate it
why do you have it eat it no oh yeah
you're gonna eat it so well
listen all right once a year my people
have a new year
okay so do my people exactly right
and so um for me it's like it's holding
you oh don't touch me
well i'm describing okay
[Laughter]
so um once a year my people um we
celebrate by
eating a durian fruit and um white
people
um are very um what much welcome and
um smell it if you if you can i smell it
from here it's
gonna smell it from closer oh you know
i'll eat it i'm down
i want to watch annie eat it no esther
you have to do it looks like
chicken
it starts as mango but then it goes foul
it goes into
bad foot really soon look okay so i
annie you eat it oh it looks like
mustard oh no we need it we need
everybody to take a taste
yeah with your hands yeah grab something
army hammer this is like very fleshy all
right
all right it smells it smells like
fermented yeah it smells fermented
eating it
look i'm from the philippines this is my
fruit and even i can't
eat it but i'm gonna do it today she's
eating it tastes delicious
of course to you annie i like it you do
yeah you spring your hand for look what
i
i like because of the [ __ ] durian
[ __ ] i cut my [ __ ]
up oh i want another one yeah yeah i
don't know what you just
just take this part it's the gizzard
part of it smells so bad give me more i
want more i'm spoiled a little brown
it's like garlicky
don't smell it just eat it it smells
like [ __ ] garbage
garlic [ __ ] eat it you eat garlic on
your [ __ ] sugar fish
[ __ ] eat the whole thing eat it put it
in your mouth and swallow it now
[ __ ] it bro it tastes like onion i don't
like it bobby i don't care it's my
[ __ ] people
all right yeah give me more let me have
something over here it tastes like a
[ __ ] like slime
you know you're a super smeller esther
and it is pretty super small
it's pretty um way more than that babe
i'm sorry
babe listen to me i'm going double
oh i'm gonna throw up
the taste does stay with you for a while
then
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is what comes out of joy diaz's
dick
[Music]
i'm not doing well i'm doing great
is